You guys know I love my dresses and my fancy outfits,
but I don't wear that 24 7.
And when I don't,
I need a really good sweatpant.
And something that I need is something comfortable,
long enough,
because I'm 6 foot tall and just easy to move in.
I love these Aritzia sweat fleece sweatpants.
They come in so many different colors,
and these are my two favorite ones.
I love a neutral color, but then
I'm also trying to branch out into wearing color.
I don't know how I feel about it yet,
but we're working on it.
They're so comfy on the inside,
and they come in two different lengths,
so I usually always go with the tall.
These sweats
are what I wear when I've clocked in for the night
and I'm just done with my day
and ready to get comfortable.